yo tout le monde sait squeeze et
aujourd'hui on se détend sur du naruto
lieu depuis ce jour l'on se retrouve sur
naruto ninja ultimate storm2 notamment
le jeu qui détient le nom de jeu le plus
nom de la planète terre de la galaxie
bref c'est parti alors je fais un petit
retour sur ce naruto parce que y'a
nouveau qui va sortir là le 5 8 mars
pardon je crois c'est m riders qui sort
le 5 bon on va faire l'histoire de mon
perso préféré on va faire alors qu'à
cacher enfin un petit mot de l'histoire
ont fait l'histoire de kakashi je sais
plus du tout comme on joue chez la
terreur en souvenir et donc ouais moi je
suis pas super fan de manga style one
piece et cetera ou quoi mais je dois
avouer que naruto c'est quand même un
peu légendaire en quelque sorte comme
manga c'est un peu un truc que tout le
monde a déjà touché quoi un peu à le
manga je pense que tout le monde a pu
voir quand on était petits un peu le
truc nous a tous attiré des ninjas et où
tout ça c'est trop stylé je mets juste
en occuper un et est du coup est là je
me suis dit [ __ ] le nouveau il sort le
8 allez on va dire adieu à l'ancien j'ai
fait quelques vidéos dessus notamment
avec lg z fin c'était assez sympa et
puis là-bas le nouveau va sortir alors
j'ai déjà eu la chance de le tester
balader - sortie le 19 la avant-hier
foncé sur le xbox live psn pour la
prendre
j'ai pas télécharger la démo à cause de
malko du maire d'un il faudra environ
deux cent vingt quatre années pour
l'avoir avant jésus-christ ça serait un
peu con pourquoi julien augé sucre et je
n'en sais rien et ambrées fouet la démo
c'est assez impressionnant on peut
battre des bosses on peut enfin je sais
pas trop comment vous dire mais ça a
l'air plus dynamiques comme combat et
c'est très prenant comme d'hab bon après
c'est vrai qu'on a eu
rise of nine aux ninjas on a eu storm2
stores mais tous génération moi j'ai
joué car raizo jeune ninja rise of ninja
je crois et a storm 2 est à bonsu la
petite histoire en même temps et
honnêtement bon c'est pas pareil c'est à
dire que raiden ya quand même un petit
peu rise of india bombes sont pas les
couilles rahil on va l'appeler doha ils
ont pu par exemple sortir se balader en
ville ou quoi et ensuite interagir avoir
des combats et ou alors que la last
dance naruto là c'est vraiment le mode
histoire de chaque perso sont pas ceux
basés dans la ville ou quoi ah on
commence quand les tout-petits [ __ ] je
trouve bien à ça va être génial y aura
oh la la c'est tellement prenant sérieux
tellement que j'adore vraiment j'adore
comment il s'appelle lui déjà ça
s'applique-t-elle hobbit ou non pas du
tout pardon c'est son pote comment il
s'appelle louis maire je me suis un peu
et voilà voilà kakashi je sais plus
comment il s'appelle même il est devenu
hokage bon bref ça fait tellement
longtemps que j'ai arrêté de suivre
naruto les scans et cetera que allez
c'est parti
passé on défonce on ne fait plus les
touches merde ça joue au pad
du coup j'ai l'habitude de tickets j'ai
trop dans la merde cologne all way au
maire mais mma comment je vais commencer
je voudrais dans son orgueil très obito
vitaux va y avoir tellement une belle
histoire
j'étais tellement ému en voyant cette
histoire d'ailleurs bon c'est de la
détente les gens si vous n'aimez pas je
comprends tout à fait j'aimerais juste
retrouver les touches g pas la boîte
malheureusement vu que c'est un jeu
gamme et nec [ __ ] merde je pourrais
pas retrouvé les touches alors y chakra
bêcher plus a sauté il ya pour se
défendre c'est une des gâchettes il me
semble bon on va voir ça tout de suite
ce marché merde merde
ah oui d'accord donc ça c'est y baissent
confère une attaque chaque fois et c'est
tout
taper tout court hu allait commencer
permute assez bon et ça c'est bon tu
vois ça va bien je peux jouer steuplé
tiens tiens tiens tiens voilà aux
caisses comme tu as pris moi j'ai marqué
un petit blanc je me souvenais plus donc
on est donc là on va donc là en fait
c'est caca chic et petits kystes bas à
l'entraînement avec donc hôpitaux ait
été très très mal instant foire à la
vache je me casse toi hôpitaux non j'ai
oublié technique
je me souviens plus bref toi qui tiens
ça leur a dit qu'ils décident permets tu
peux y as et turcs ont souri en fait
j'ai les mains glacées
c'est tellement dur de jouer avec les
mains glacées jo asahi maîtriser déjà ça
c'est vraiment un bon et si je passe aux
mains des belges et koala ou nomades et
paye sexe avec le petit katana tiens
tiens tiens là l'écran et vibrer tout
n'est pas content ou la vache à lait
apli et son doublé gragbé je sais quoi
penser
il est vraiment bas les sceptiques à
cacher plus tard donc ouais donc voilà
je voulais juste faire un petit dernière
vidéo sur ce naruto la pire on se
retrouvera sur le prochain que je vais
faire une joie de prendre
je me demande ce qu'ils ont pu nous
faire comme surprise chez que fut
l'attenté rives la boétie et [ __ ] j'ai
un million de rio un million trois cent
cinquante mille avec à signaler ok bon
c'est bon j'ai repris un petit peu le
truc en main en main glacée à -18 degrés
voyez-vous fait tellement froid dehors
les gens c'est un truc de malade 60 ans
moi je suis crevé je bâtis sa et étoile
matin tu as le matin c'est une épreuve
oh la la c'est abuser c'est quand tu es
dans ton lit au chaud tu te réveilles
sonne que tu te dis ah ah ah ah je suis
si bien su la couette fait tellement
froid en dehors je dois aller en cours
allaient en peluche et un réveil je me
rends dans c'est arrivé au moins une
fois par mois tout le monde aussi
persuadé bonsoir fou un peu l'histoire
de façon c'est moi qui vais vous
raconter l'histoire donc laisse bacon
son maître ah ça va être bon pour
rigoler il n'est pas sérieux ils se
remettent pas je te défonce m non c'est
bien évidemment pour rigoler alors c'est
parti
on va essayer de se faire bien comme il
faut dans les règles de l'art on y
arrive ma foi un autocollant
autocollants aller et il est tellement
plus fort au but où aller au combat ils
sont venus fêter son entier aux bâtards
non au
ou la vache ça fait très très mal alors
attendez on va refaire y a non je t'aime
état de partir là tiens [ __ ] sais mais
ça permute en fait cette écoute dont
know tous les gens c'est de lorsque le
mec il mais ça permute tu fais tu fais
y a et tu vas dire est que courir sur
lui il n'y aura pas comme ça hop là il a
reculé
waouh ça se traite à voilà si ça
d'antijeu que question naruto j'avais
oublié c'est de faire de faire permut
que greg b c'est très très large que moi
je suis au top à merde j'ai vu leur père
y là mais ça peut marcher à alger du
combo ma foi du prochain remaniement
allez on a ça en cover on retourne
souligner est là que le sait bien elle a
pas de technique
alors quoi qu'il fasse soleil pour que
je passe à y intégrer twitter oh la
vache
mais très cher
jamais faire le grand saut avec 100 mais
[ __ ] mais il est super chiant arrête
de courir bordel or là par contre si
passant dans l'oreille des gens je
trouve tellement cher faut pas que je
laisse aller au bout je les fais mon
cher tranquille toi qui on peut même pas
choisir la mode de difficulté dans sa
hotte de noël
on l'a eu très bien alors pour info
pourquoi j'ai pris quelques chips que
bon bah c'est mon perso préféré comme
j'ai dit est mon premier de ce dossier
les jeux et tous étaient kaka chu se
doute très originales tirées de la base
prédomine à lca cash comme kakashi et de
la base près nominale de mon prénom
lucas ce qui donne quand tu fais un mix
des deux kaka lui au jeu demain à
tonnerre d'applaudissements pour cette
originalité et ses bras moi tu me diras
c'est mieux que x pict the dark dog
marteau de thor hulk xd ptdr bouclier
america iron man c'est un peu con xx
attend il ya là si pressés et wesh tu
peut les repérer en jeu il met toujours
xx machin du 9-2 machin du 9 juin wesh
wesh il met 2009 quelque chose leur
département c'est juste trop marrante
alors si un petit peu l'histoire mais
alors si vous n'êtes on va regarder les
choses cette expression désolé bravo
suite que signifiait cette opération
peut que manquer turin tanja g 100
passes pour que je comprenne enfin et
alors être manquer quoi ah voilà ça
travail d'équipé sur binck à l'époque au
but où tu vas sacrée fête à vie pour me
lancer dans les shows homonyme ok voilà
c'est ça que j'avais vraiment bad et
quand j'ai vu ça s'est il est mort et il
en fait mieux que les yeux que tu
défends question aujourd'hui enfin
toujours à graulhet dans la chair et
dans leur aussi mort et bien sûr ils
n'ont pas compris tout de suite ou le
mauvais genre l'équipe ils avaient tous
connu des périodes difficiles surtout
naruto sasuke in the dry l'équipe
n'était pas naturel par nicolas gob pour
moi leur âge
c'est pourquoi je l'enseigné comnat
autres ce qui était important pour un
hymne jaunards le potage de sasuke je
crois vraiment la tendance est caché
donc ouais en fait au but où il s'est
fait écraser par un rocher fin par un
mec est en gros il a il a demandé aux
médecins de l'équipe qui était avec
akashi de lui donner son âge
voilà on va faire un naruto contre
contre ce quelque chose c'est à dire que
kaka qui en fait sont sharingan il le
tire de son pote obito qui a demandé
justement bas
à la fille qui était avec elle mais là
la médecin de balhaf et vas-y de
montagnac à cacher et tout c'est un truc
peut me prendre et tout mais il est en
plus obito est super fort dans le jeu en
fait je pense que dans le jeu de combat
comme naruto et et cagna il n'y a pas
vraiment de persos plus cheap et du
d'autres en soit il à des techniques
d'antijeu grammont chantal chez claranet
mais il n'y a pas vraiment de d'antijeu
de ouf voilà on va dire que c'est colour
salut aux bâtards rats et lapins batman
aa casse toi oh la vache stage récupère
mais peut dire que là je me défonce et
des ponts saint lô en tee shirt yes ça
marchait à venise balade suis fait bon
remarque moi ta tion j'appelle un peu
tous les autres joueurs techniques
introduites comme ça j'appelle ça
tu arrêtes un taux à baltard alors ça
génial alors poussé qu'ils connaissent
rien à rothau je vous conseille de
prendre le dessus ça c'est sûr mais je
vous conseille de prendre le prochain
quand même parce que ça vaut le coup
c'est un petit jeu de combat un peu pas
comme tekken est intéressant quand même
et je vous conseille sincèrement de
prendre honnêtement c'est vraiment pas
mal c'est vraiment pas mal ça change un
peu de jus fps du tekken fâche pas trop
comment vous dire mais c'est qu'on est
passé à côté de la route au chocolat
puis en même temps les gens sortent un
endroit marque un temps à mes ta gueule
j'attends bouffer des shurikens no 6 les
grecs x y x tu en auras joué avec lui y
x parchemin y fit marche pas ils
appliquent
l'apache nommé chien ta gueule au mnr
tiens tiens tiens puisque tu pues l'adar
auto la suite on m antijeu merde au jeu
des vacances et celui là a fait son
[ __ ] de salut qui est de merde
reiner ben oui mineurs tiens non tient
aux [ __ ] merde on va perdre la bataille
de loos non on va faire ses bagages
ajouterait très tactique les crises et
moi tout changement chakra pendant petit
fils à papa techno pop n'ont toujours
pas comme ça alors un bâtard et allegro
de skis
tiens un petit pet de merde avec tes
cheveux en épi tapage et sangoku terme
et encore pas tous deux fois qui est la
leur oh la la il met tellement ma misère
des fois non
voilà face aux la page va pas le faire
at what have you know [ __ ] l'enculé de
blanc [ __ ] mais la vache noire et
s'est offert un petit cri pour montrer
mon mécontentement qui hérite bien la
gorge quand les malades
là mon gars je te laisse même pas bougé
alors la terre mais des fois ça belin je
fais la commune et on touche à mes
quatre on tiens tiens je trouve que l'on
sait que des chiens aux rudes technique
du pain par besoin c'était plus rond toi
mon gars c'est non allez au revoir
monsieur
oh mais il est sérieux il a pu perdre
mais j'en ai deux gels avantage pour un
tout petit peu de chaque rail et non
parfait je prends pas ton chakra dessus
et voilà aller si loin cette fois on va
la voir des bras la turquie se m
on cherche un peu le chakra des kits
scolaires compteront sur lui on l'aimé
saâd el arif ps et permet il récupère
ces permis sont en fait ce qui est
chouette leur auto voilà c'est ça temps
forts les merdes fait des colonies se
cache derrière temps de bâtard tuant
douze toi ça pour toi ça j'ai dit énervé
c'est moi qui contrôle
je contrôle la zone oui oh oui à ratures
franck tellement cher bouquet de fruits
et un c est pas moi à cause à l'ordre la
deuxième barre de vimont et inamoto tard
les joueurs absents
non
müller tient pas tout boucler un tas de
faire ça tiens moi je te les coups de
chien mais en fait ils font pas tout
bref c'est pas mal en fait
à un moment je le fais à bata roman je
le fais ouais ouais bon hâter les choses
on retourne en leur nom y avait des mecs
comme ça comme un abri pour qu'ils n'ont
rien faut suivre au maire ont des
attaquants blanche et voilà on
enchaînera chèvre un chien nommé
turrican petites robes bataille de ce
qui les attend pas ta merde j'ai plus
prenant
wassim bas les gens comment je rage oui
monsieur relevé en grosse [ __ ] un petit
coup bim
oh [ __ ] quel stress incroyable ouais
donc je suis grave intrigué par ce
nouveau naruto
j'ai hâte qu'il sorte en fait simplement
tester enfin les petites doses ou quoi
ça peut être très sympa et puis voilà
mon chèque cette vidéo il ya énormément
de gens qui la verront parce que naruto
les gens ils s'en foutent un petit peu
ce que je comprends mais j'ai envie de
dire ouvrez vous un petit peu essayé de
voir même si vous n'avez jamais lu le
manga ou quoi et c'est quand même
détester naruto ne serait-ce que
demander à votre pote de vous le prêter
aux quoi puis vous verrez que des fois
bas c'est super drôle en fait de faire
des tournois naoto autant que faire des
tournois tekken c'est vraiment un truc
drôle et puis un modèle alors de nouveau
gagner les batailles plus talentueux
mais a trouvé sa voie ouais c'est vrai
ce test assez drôle dans tout ça
on y prépare sa vengeance voilà donc ça
ce week-end par signes très longue
histoire en plus je crois qu'à cacher
leur union il part donc on a 16 du kaki
par qui quitte le groupe
et voilà donc là on est quand même
quelques années plus tard après leur
entraînement quand ils reviennent de
leur entraînement en fait bientôt donc
s'est entraîné que gérald a ajouté avec
ah [ __ ] la celle qui est devenue un
tollé chez q&a mère je sais plus le nom
et du coup voilà il leur propose d'en
faire le même exercice qu'à l'époque
donc ça va être drôle cette fois et les
grands va se faire défoncer et ouais et
à prix vont partir à la chasse aux
syndiqués je crois que cette histoire
dure bien trente minutes en fait on
avoir un paquet de temps mais ses parts
à écouter moi j'aime bien moi j'aime
bien lyon
alors attention aux tricheurs richard
c'est ça ouais tu veux pas le jardin de
temps bastien milhas bachique pas contre
la faim la vraie comme ici
non
yes parmi les robes en fait c'est que
c'est chaque fois on va dégager c'est
que je dis à chaque fois c'est geof à
chaque fois
et c'est un bâtard un bâtard alors à
bata
yes à gauche dont il a il a plus de
permis en fait ce qui est un petit peu
des dents tantôt par précédemment c'est
pour les permis sont les faits tout en
fait qu'enfler ces deux captages plus
comment on fait c'est simple mais c'est
quoi jouent ils gardent trop craquer
monga des rôles chez toi naruto là bas
mot gd oui toutes les victimes enlevées
quoi comme il y avait tellement pas
cliché mais [ __ ] mais sa fille aulas
mes mecs mais aulas alors toi mec
tiens mais là mais tu vas trouver on
éclaire un bon gars mais dont il abuse
quoi voilà la vache c'est quoi
s'emballer veille ça fait peur
à l'ope allez hop cas question de level
up et voilà donc ça c'est pas me charles
gaines qui la voulait apprendre que
positive et a donné là du coup les poux
fait bien plus mal il va bien plus de
galles et l'âme avoir gelé avantage sur
lui préfère voir mais je passe juste ça
et là grosse mais voilà donc ça fait un
petit mal logement
boum même pas on est pas se coller on
sache pas se relever et voilà enfin
tantôt le mode des boys et le droit -
après gras gay disait robert on aurait
besoin le matin du mot d'éveil croyait
on continue ni vu ni connu
petite blague glace donc on les avons
assez de ça c'est moi que je suis très
très mauvais ma foi très très très
mauvaise idée on se pose pas ces eaux du
tout ça pas sérieux du tout
enregistrement en cours
ouais tout à fait chargement 100% et y
est moins bon choix je plaiderai je fais
la vidéo que je dis je pense que je
ferai le vendredi parce qu'une société
incroyable voilà qui excédé les attentes
les plus folles sont non ce n'est pas
seulement la force
bon bref en boissons fortes pour vin
compris ah ça lui fait penser à lui à et
ses deux coéquipiers comme isabelle
quand il avait le même âge mais se
faisait fort mais c'est triste quand
même pas ce qui lui arrivait alors
chinois rck le travail d'équipé l'amitié
agrémenté par les auditoires hobbit all
in et le maître se sont tranquillement
tard oui oui c'est vrai sauf ce soir est
maintenant himawari dessous de ces
gamins oui bon allez on passe on passe
on passe les gens à passer quatre mois
sur cette thématique
du coup on connaît l'histoire de manière
dont je vous la raconte oh non c'était
la fin non c'est une blague
abassi
ok bon moi c'était l'histoire de cash et
messieurs dames c'est est bref et
amusant moi j'aime bien ce cas son père
préférait si vous voulez d'autres vidéos
détente un peu posé comme ça n'hésitez
pas à me demander j'en ferai et puis moi
là je vais aller je vais aller faire des
vidéos sur un sorte de thunder bay sera
sûrement un peu le même jour où le
samedi je sais pas et puis voilà déjà
tout le monde pc à bientôt